[Music]
Ben Shapiro is an American journalist
who panders to the neoconservative
movement in America, the alt-right
movement, and who has been refuted many
times by myself,
many times. I don't know how many views
it's all rad up now. Hundreds of
thousands, maybe a million views. I
don't know. But we keep slapping him
online. We keep slapping him online and
he keeps taking and absorbing the slaps.
And I say, "Continue. I'm going to give
you another one today. Get your face
ready. Get your cheeks ready. I'm going
to slap you again today. I'm going to
slap you again." And yeah, you can try
and reply because recently he tried to
retweet something which had me in the in
a in a Palestinian the pro Palestinian
march saying that for us as Muslims life
begins at death which is probably the
most the least controversial statement
any religious person can make. Every
religious person almost every religious
person believes
that life begins at death. And yes, of
course, I was talking about the
Palestinian struggle. You think this is
some kind of golden bullet? Is this your
fight back? After hundreds of thousands
of views, arguments upon arguments,
attack upon attack, intellectual assault
upon intellectual assault, this is what
you try and respond with. How
embarrassing.
How absolutely embarrassing. What I want
to do in this video today is outline
three main points.
Looking at his tweets and looking at his
behavior, especially with the Palestine
Israel conflict, it's very clear that
Ben Shapiro wants to promote a culture
of sensoriousness,
a gag culture, a gag culture where he
tries to alienate and ostracize those
who go against the standard narrative,
the standard pro-Israeli narrative. And
it's really ironic that he of all people
does this being a spokesperson
for or pundit for neoconservatives
using freedom of speech as some kind of
pretext for for refuting and dismantling
the transgenders and the feminists and
uh others on the left. But when it comes
to the state of Israel, he acts just
like those people
who he criticizes,
he starts labeling people as
anti-semitic. In fact, he tries to
confuse and conflate anti-semitism with
anti-ionism.
And he even says that there's a point of
convergence between the two things.
Let's see what he has to say on these
matters. There's a point where being
anti-Israel shifts over into being
anti-semitic. Okay, the conflation
between anti-ionism, Zionism and
anti-semitism, not everybody who doesn't
like Israel is an anti-semite, but every
anti-semit is anti-Israel.
So, you see here, this is a threat, a
threatening behavior of I will label you
if you don't agree with my narrative.
This is pathetic. Use your label. Use
your label. Go ahead, do your worst.
We're not scared of your label. Calling
us anti-semites when in fact we are
Semites. I'm a Semite myself. Arabs are
Semites and Arabic is a Seemetic
language.
At any rate, you can call me whatever
you like. This does not change the fact
that you have not been able to answer a
single argument that has been made. And
you know what else you have not been
able to do? You have not been able to
make one singular solitary condemnation
of the 66 children that have been killed
in cold blood by the policies of the
Israelis that you defend.
Now, you may remember some time ago you
made a video talking about the Muslim
radical myth and you talked about the
Muslim moderate myth or I can't remember
what you named the title but you were
basically making the point that all of
these Muslims are following Sharia law
or believe in it and therefore there is
this many radicals in Muslim radicals in
the world. What kind of ridiculous
notion is that? In fact, if we assume
that radicalism so defined is when
someone supports or does action to
terrorize
a civilian population, a non-combatant
population, then tell me how Israel is
absolved from being terroristic or
radical from that perspective and how
your support for Israel in its targeting
of civilian populations is not itself a
type of radical reflection. In that
analysis, you're radical. You are a
radical. Stop pointing the fingers of
all these Muslims that believe in Sharia
law, which they might have different
opinions on what it means when in fact
you're the radical one because you are
the one who makes videos about abortion.
You make videos about abortion and you
label it as killing children. Abortion
is killing children. But when the
governments that you support, which is
the Israeli government, actually kill
children, you have nothing to say about
that, do you? You have no condemnation
about that, do you? So, it's not, and
stop pretending
that you care about children. You don't
care about babies being killed. You only
care about certain babies being killed
by certain political opponents of yours.
If it's a leftist
doing abortion, that's killing babies.
But when it's an Israeli dropping bombs
in the most densely populated civilian
areas and 66 children die, you support
that state. You are a walking
contradiction. And how dare you even
show your face in a public sphere after
you've contradicted yourself so severely
like that.
You embarrass yourself. you embarrass
yourself. And you know what I say? I say
for all of those neoconservatives and
alt-right people that follow you, do not
let this man and his likes. I'm saying
this very clearly. Pro-Zionists and his
likes. Do not let this man fool you into
making exceptions.
Yes, you're making moral and political
exceptions for the state of Israel. If
your mantra is we believe in freedom of
speech and freedom of expression,
we we're avoid a culture of
sensoriousness and we're avoid we're
averse to sorry a a a culture of
sensoriousness,
then you can't go ahead and agree with
someone or show support to someone who
promotes such culture and who uses
labeling. everyone who doesn't agree
with him. Rashid Talib
in America, you call her an anti-semite.
You call another AOC. Yeah. An
anti-Semite. This person is anti-Mite.
This person's anti-Mite. To be honest
with you, not much difference between
what you and the left does by calling
this person the racist and this one the
bigot and this one the
You're doing the same thing. You're
pathetic. You're trying to crush public
discourse by censoring and labeling.
We're not afraid of your labels. In
fact, there's a verse in the Quran and
I'm going to end with this verse of
Quran. It states in chapter 10 when
Noah,
he says, "If my reminder to you people,"
he says this to his people, Noah, "If my
reminder to you people and my standing
with your people and my reminder to your
people is too big for you to bear, then
I
I rely upon Allah. I rely upon God.
I rely upon God. So you bring together
your plots and plans. Bring together
your plots and plans and your affair
and don't have any hesitation.
Do not have any hesitation in your plan.
Meaning do your worst. Do your worst to
us and don't even give us time. Don't
give us any restbite.
We are ready for you.